alright hello everybody hopefully you
can hear me well yes yes great so
welcome to course six s0 9 for deep
learning for self-driving cars we will
introduce to you the methods of deep
learning of deep neural networks using
the guiding case study of building
self-driving cars my name is Lex
Friedman you get to listen to me for
majority of these lectures and I am part
of an amazing team with some brilliant
TAS would you say brilliant to Dan Dan
Brown you guys want to stand up ok there
in front row Spencer
William and Joe Spencer died and all the
way in the back the smartest and the
tallest person I know
Benedict genic so well you see there on
the left of the slide is a visualization
of one of the two projects that one of
the two simulations games that will get
to go through we use it as a way to
teach you about deep reinforcement
learning but also as a way to excite
excite you by challenging you to compete
against others if you wish to win a
special prize yet to be announced
super secret prize so you can reach me
and the TAS at Deep cars that mit.edu if
you have any questions about the
tutorials about the lecture about
anything at all the website cars that
mit.edu has the lecture content code
tutorials again like today the lecture
slides for today are already up in PDF
form this the the slides themselves if
you want to see them just email me but
they're over a gigabyte in size because
they're very heavy in videos so I'm just
posting the PDFs and there will be
lecture videos available
a few days after the lecture is given so
speaking of which there is a camera in
the back this is being videotaped and
recorded but for the most part the
camera is just on the speaker so you
shouldn't have to worry if that kind of
thing worries you then you could sit on
the periphery of the classroom or maybe
I suggest sunglasses and the moustache
fake mustache it would be a good idea
there is a competition for the game that
you see on the left I'll describe
exactly what's involved in order to get
credit for the course you have to design
a neural network that drives the car
just above the speed limit 65 miles an
hour but if you want to win you need to
go a little faster than that so what who
this class is for you maybe neither
programming
noodle machine learning new to robotics
or you're an experts in those fields but
want to go back to the basics so what
you will learn is an overview of deep
reinforcement learning a convolutional
neural networks recurrent neural
networks and how these methods can help
improve each of the components of
autonomous driving perception visual
perception localization mapping control
planning and the detection of driver
state okay two projects codename deep
traffic is the first one there is in
this particular formulation of it there
is seven lanes it's a top view it looks
like a game but I assure you it's very
serious
it is the agent in red the car in red is
being controlled by a neural network and
will explain how you can control and
design the various aspects of the
various parameters of this nono this
neural network and it learns in the
browser so this we're using ComNet Jas
which is a library that is programmed by
andraka Parthi in JavaScript
so amazingly we live in a world where
you can train in a matter of minutes a
neural network in your browser and we'll
talk about how to do that the reason we
did this is so that there is very few
requirements forget you up and started
when you're all networks so in order to
complete this project for the course you
don't need any requirements except to
have a Chrome browser and to win the
competition you don't need anything
except the Chrome browser
the second project codenamed EEP Tesla
or Tesla is using data from a Tesla
vehicle of the forward roadway and using
m10 learning taking the image the and
putting it into convolutional neural
network that directly Maps a regresar
that maps to a steering angle so all it
takes is a single image and it predicts
a steering angle for the car and you we
have data for the car itself and you get
to build a neural network that tries to
do better tries to steer better or at
least as good as the car okay let's get
started with the question with the thing
that we understand so poorly at this
time because it's so shrouded in mystery
but it fascinates many of us and that's
the question of what is intelligence
this is from a 1996 march 1996 Time
magazine and the question can machines
think is answered below where they
already do so what if anything is
special about the human mind it's a good
question for 1996 a good question for
2016-17 now and the future and there's
two ways to ask that question one is the
special purpose version
can art efficient an artificial
intelligence system achieve us well
defined specifically formally defined
finite set of goals and this little
diagram from a book that got me into
artificial intelligence as a bright-eyed
high school student the artificial
intelligence a modern approach this is a
beautifully simple diagram of an Intel
over system it exists in an environment
it has a set of sensors that do the
perception it takes those sensors in
does something magical there's a
question mark there and with a set of
effectors acts in the world manipulates
objects in that world and so
special-purpose we can under this
formulation as long as the environment
is formally defined well defined as long
as the set of goals are well-defined as
long as the set of actions sensors and
the ways that the perception cares
itself out is well-defined we have good
algorithms of which we'll talk about
that can optimize for those goals the
question is if we inch along this path
will we get closer to the general
formulation to the general purpose
version of what artificial intelligence
is can it achieve poorly defined
unconstrained set of goals with an
unconstrained poorly defined set of
actions and unconstrained poorly defined
utility functions rewards this is what
human life is about this is what we do
pretty well most days exists in a
undefined full of uncertainty world so
ok we can separate tasks into different
three different categories formal tasks
this is the easiest it doesn't seem so
it didn't seem so at the birth of
artificial intelligence but that's in
fact true if you think about
the easiest is the formal tasks playing
board games theorem proving all the kind
of mathematical logic problems that can
be formalized formally defined then
there's the expert expert tasks so this
is this is where a lot of the exciting
breakthroughs have been happening where
machine learning methods data-driven
methods can help aid or improve on the
performance of our human experts this
means medical diagnosis hardware design
scheduling and then there is the thing
that we take for granted the trivial
thing the thing that we do so easily
every day when we wake up in the morning
the mundane tasks of everyday speech of
written language of visual perception of
walking which we'll talk about in
today's lecture is a fascinatingly
difficult task and object manipulation
so the question is that we're asking
here before we talk about deep learning
before we talk about the specific
methods we really want to dig in and and
and try to see what is it about driving
how difficult is driving is it more like
chess which you see on the left there
where we can formally define a set of
lanes a set of actions and formulate it
as this you know there's five set of
actions you can change your lane you can
avoid obstacles that there's you can
formally define an obstacle you can
formally define the rules of the road or
is is there something about natural
language something similar to everyday
conversation about driving that requires
a much higher degree of reasoning of
communication of learning of existing in
his under actuated space it's a lot more
than just left lane right lane speed up
slow down so let's look at it as a chess
game here's the chess pieces what is
what
the senses we get to work within a self
on an autonomous vehicle and we'll get a
lot more in depth on this especially
with the guest speakers who built many
of these there's radar there's the range
sensors radar lidar that give you
information about the obstacles in your
environment they'll help localize the
obstacles in the environment
there's the visible light camera and
stereo vision that gives you texture
information that helps you figure out
not just where the obstacles are but
what they are helps to classify those
has to understand they're subtle
movements then there is the information
about the vehicle itself about the
trajectory in the movement of the
vehicle that comes from the GPS and I'm
you sensors and there is the state of
the the rich state of the vehicle itself
what is it doing what are all the
individual systems doing that comes from
the can Network and there there is one
of the less studied but fascinating to
us on the research side is audio the
sounds of the road that provide the rich
context of a wet road the sound of a
road that wouldn't stop raining but it's
still wet the sound that it makes the
screeching tire and nothing honking
these are all fascinating signals as
well and the focus of the research in
our group the thing that's really much
under investigated is the internal
facing sensors the driver sensing the
the state of the driver where are they
looking are they sleepy the emotional
state are they in the seat at all and
the same with audio that comes from the
visual information and the audio
information more than that here's the
tasks if you were to break into modules
the task of what it means to build a
self-driving vehicle first you want to
know where you are
where
my localization and mapping you want to
map the external environment figure out
where all the different obstacles are
all the entities are and use that
estimate of the environment to then
figure out where I am where the robot is
then there's scene understanding its
understanding not just the positional
aspects of the external environment and
the dynamics of it but also what those
entities are is it a car is that a
pedestrian is it a bird there's movement
planning once you have kind of figured
out to the best of your abilities your
position and the position of other
entities in this world there's figuring
out a trajectory through that world and
finally once you've figured out how to
move about safely and effectively
through that world is figuring out what
the human that sounding board is doing
because as I will talk about the path to
a self-driving vehicle and that is hence
our focus on Tesla may go through semi
autonomous vehicles where there is a
where the vehicle must not only drive
itself but effectively hand over control
from the car to the human and back ok
quick history well there's a lot of fun
stuff from the 80s and 90s but the the
the big breakthroughs came when in the
second DARPA Grand Challenge with
Stanford Stanley when they won the
competition one of five cars that
finished this was an incredible
accomplishment in a desert race a fully
autonomous vehicle was able to complete
the race in record time
the DARPA urban challenge in 2007 where
the race was the the task was no longer
race to the desert but through a urban
environment and CMU's boss with GM won
that race and a lot of that work led
directly into the acceptance and large
major industry players taking on the
challenge of building these vehicles
Google now way mo self-driving car Tesla
with its autopilot system and not
autopilot to system uber with its
testing in Pittsburgh then there's many
other companies including one of the
speakers for this course of metonymy
that are driving the the wonderful
streets of Boston okay so let's take a
step back we have if we think about the
accomplishments in the DARPA challenge
and if we look at the accomplishments of
the Google self-driving car which
essentially boils the world down into a
chess game it uses incredibly accurate
sensors to build a three-dimensional map
of the world localize itself effective
in that world and move about that world
in a very well-defined way now what if
driving the open question is if driving
is more like a conversation like a
natural language conversation how hard
is it to pass the Turing test the Turing
test as the popular current formulation
is can a computer Miss be mistaken for a
human being in more than 30 percent of
the time when a human is talking behind
a veil
a conversation with their computer a
human can they mistake the other side of
that conversation for being a human when
it's in fact the computer and the the
way you would in a natural language
build a system that has successfully
passes the Turing test is the natural
language part the processing part to
enable it to communicate successfully so
generate language and interpret language
then you represent knowledge the state
of the conversation transferred over
time and the last piece and this is the
hard piece is the automated reasoning
its reasoning can we teach machine
learning methods to reason that's that
is something that will propagate through
our discussion because as I will talk
about the various methods the various
deep learning methods neural networks
are good at learning from data but
they're not yet there's no good
mechanism for reasoning now reasoning
could be just something that we tell
ourselves we do to feel special better
to feel like we're better than machines
reasoning may be simply something as
simple as learning from data we just
need a larger Network or there could be
a totally different mechanism acquired
and we'll talk about the possibilities
there yes
no it's it's very difficult to find
these kind of situations in the United
States so the question was for this
video is it in the United States or not
I believe it's in Tokyo so India a few
European countries are much are much
more towards the direction of natural
language versus chess in the United
States generally speaking we follow
rules more concretely the quality of
roads is better the marking on the roads
is better so there's less requirements
there
these cars are driving the left side oh
I see I just okay yeah you're right it
is cuz yep yeah so but it's certainly
not the United States I'm pretty I'm
from it's spent quite a bit of googling
trying to find in the United States and
it's it's difficult so let's talk about
the recent breakthroughs in machine
learning and what is it the core of
those breakthroughs as neural networks
that have been around for a long time
and I will talk about what has changed
what are the cool new things and what s
hasn't changed and what are its
possibilities but first a neuron crudely
is a computational building block of the
brain I know there's a few folks here
neuroscience folks this is hardly a
model it is mostly an inspiration and so
the the human neuron has inspired the
artificial neuron the computational
building block of a neural network of an
artificial neural network now to give
you some context these neurons for both
artificial and human brains are
interconnected and the human brain
there's about I believe 10,000 outgoing
connections from every neuron an average
and they're interconnected to each other
are the largest current as far as I'm
aware artificial neural network has ten
billion of those connections synapses
our human brain to the best estimate
that I'm aware
has 10,000 times that so a hundred to
one thousand trillion synapses now what
is a artificial neuron this building
block of a neural network it takes a set
of inputs it puts a weight on each of
those inputs sums them together applies
a bias value on each that that sits on
each neuron and using an activation
function that takes as input V that sum
plus the bias and squishes it together
to produce a zero to one signal
and this allows us a single neuron to
take a few inputs and produces an output
a classification for example 0 1 and as
we'll talk about simply it it can serve
as a linear classifier so it can draw a
line it can learn to draw a line between
like what's seen here between the blue
dots and the yellow dots and that's
exactly what we'll do in the ipython
notebook that I'll talk about but the
basic algorithm is you initialize the
the weights on the inputs and you
compute the output you perform this
previous operation that I talked about
sum up and compute the output and if the
output does not match the ground truth
the expected output the output that it
should produce the weights are punished
accordingly and we'll talk through a
little bit of the math of that and this
process is repeated until the perceptron
does not make any more mistakes now
here's the amazing thing about neural
networks
there's several I'll talk about them one
on the mathematical side is the
universality of neural networks with
just a single layer if we stack them
together a single hidden layer the
inputs on the left the outputs on the
right and in the middle there's a single
hidden layer it can closely approximate
any function any function so this is an
incredible property that with a single
layer any function you could think of
that you know you can think of driving
as a function it takes an input the
world outside as output to control the
vehicle there exists a neural network
out there that can drive perfectly it's
a fascinating mathematical fact so we
can think of this then these functions
as a special-purpose function special
purpose intelligence you can take say as
input the number of bedrooms the square
feet the type of neighborhood those are
the three inputs it passes that value
through to the hidden layer and then one
more step it produces the final price
estimate for the house or for the
residence and we can teach a network to
do this pretty well in a supervised way
this is supervised learning you provide
a lot of examples where you know the
number of bedrooms the square feet the
type of neighborhood and then you'll
also know the final price of the house
or the residence and then you can as
I'll talk about through a process of
back propagation teach these networks to
make this prediction pretty well now
some of the exciting breakthroughs
recently have been in the general
purpose intelligence this is from Andre
Carr parthy who's now at open AI I would
like to take a moment here to try to
explain how amazing this is this is a
game of pong if you're not familiar with
pong there's two paddles and you're
trying to bounce the ball back and in
such a way that prevents the other guy
from bouncing the wall of the ball back
you on the the the play the artificial
intelligence agent is on the right and
green and up top is the score eight to
one now this takes about three days to
Train on a regular computer this network
what is this network doing it's called
the policy Network the input is the raw
pixels the there they're slightly
processed and also you take the
difference between two frames but it's
basically the raw pixel information
that's the input there's a few hidden
layers and the output is a single
probability of moving up that that's it
that's that's the whole that's that's
the whole system and what it's doing is
it learns not you don't know at any one
moment
you don't know what the right thing to
do is is it to move up is it to move
down you only know what the right thing
to do is by the fact that eventually you
win or lose the game so this is the
amazing thing here is there's no
supervised learning about there's no
like universal fact about anyone's name
being good or bad and anyone actually
being good about in any state but if you
punish or reward every single action you
took every single action you took for
entire game based on the result so no
matter what you did if you won the game
the end justifies the means
if you won the game every action you
took and every every action state pair
gets rewarded if you lost the game it
gets punished and this process with only
200,000 games where the the the system
just simulates the games it can learn to
beat the computer
this system knows nothing about pong
nothing about games this is general
intelligence except for the fact that
it's just a game of pong and I will talk
about how this can be extended further
why this is so promising and why this is
also we should proceed with caution so
again there's a set of actions you take
up-down up-down based on the output of
the network there's a threshold give
them the probability of moving up you
move up or down based on the output of
the network and you have a set of states
and every single state action pair is
awarded if there's a win and it's
punished if there's a loss when you go
home think about how amazing that is and
if you don't understand why that's
amazing
spend some time on it it's incredible
okay sure sure thing the question was
what is supervised learning what is
unsupervised learning what's the
difference so supervised learning is
when people talk about machine learning
they mean supervised learning most of
the time supervised learning is learning
from data it's learning from example
when you have a set of inputs and a set
of outputs they that you know are
correct what are called ground truth so
you need those examples a large amount
of them to train any of the machine
learning algorithms to learn to then
generalize that to future examples this
is
actually there's a third one called
reinforcement learning where the ground
truth is sparse the information about
when something is good or not the groud
truth only happens every once in a while
at the end of the game not every single
frame and unsupervised learning is when
you have no information about the
outputs that are correct or incorrect
and it is the excitement of the deep
learning community is unsupervised
learning but it has achieved no major
breakthroughs at this point this is the
I'll talk about what the future deep
learning is and a lot of the people that
are working in the field are excited by
it but right now every except any
interesting accomplishment is has to do
with supervised learning
yeah and the Brahmin is just a heuristic
solution like you are look at them in
philosophy so basically the
reinforcement learning here is learning
from somebody who has certain rules and
how can that be guaranteed that we will
generalize to somebody else so this it's
a the question was this the parallel the
green paddle learns to play this game
successfully against this specific one
brown paddle with us operating under
specific kinds of rules how do we know
it can generalize to other games other
things and it can't but the mechanism by
which it learns generalizes so as long
as you let it play as long as you let it
play in whatever world you want it to
succeed in long enough it will use the
same approach to learn to succeed in
that world the problem is you this works
for worlds you can simulate well
unfortunately the one of the big
challenges of neural networks is that
we're not they're not currently
efficient learners we need a lot of data
to learn anything human beings need like
need one example often times and they
learn very efficiently from that one
example so and again I'll talk about
that as well it's a good question
so the drawbacks of neural networks so
if you think about the way a human being
would approach this game this game of
pong they would only need a simple set
of instructions you're in control of a
paddle and you can move it up and down
and your task is to bounce the ball past
the other player controlled by AI now
human being would immediately they may
not win the game but they would
immediately understand the game and will
be able to successfully play it well
enough to pretty quickly learn to beat
the game but they need to have a concept
of control
what it means to control a paddle they
need to have a concept of a paddle then
you have a concept of moving up and down
and a ball and bouncing they have to
know they have to have a at least a
loose concept of real-world physics that
they can then project that real-world
physics onto the two-dimensional world
all of these concepts are our concepts
that you come to the table with that's
knowledge and the kind of way you
transfer that knowledge from from your
previous experience from from childhood
to now when you come to this game that
is something is called reasoning
whatever reasoning means and the
question is whether through this same
kind of process you can see the entire
world as a game of pong and reasoning is
simply ability to simulate that game in
your mind and learn very efficiently
much more efficiently than two-hundred
thousand iterations the other challenge
of deep neural networks and machine
learning broadly is you need big data
and efficient learners they said that
data also needs to be supervised data
you need to have ground truth which is
very costly for - annotation a human
being looking at a particular image for
example and labeling that as something
as a cat or a dog whatever object is in
the image that's very costly and for
particularly for neural networks there's
a lot of parameters to tune there's a
lot of hyper parameters you need to
figure out the network structure first
how does this network look how many
layers
I mean you hidden
what type of what type of activation
folks that a known there's a lot of
hyper parameters there and then once you
built your network there is parameters
for how you teach that network there's
learning rate loss function mini batch
size number of training iterations
gradient update smoothing and the
selecting even the optimizer with which
you with which you solve the various
differential equations involved it's a
topic of many research paper certainly
it's rich enough for research papers but
it's also really challenging it's means
that you can't just pop and network down
and it will solve the problem generally
and defining a good loss function or in
the case of pong or games a good reward
function is difficult so here's a game
this is a recent result from open AI I'm
teaching a network to play the game of
coast runners and the goal of coast
runners is to go you're in a boat you're
the task is to go around a track and
successfully complete a race against
other people you're racing against now
this network is an optimal one and what
is figured out that actually in the game
it's gets a lot of points for collecting
certain objects along the path so you
see is it's figured out to go in a
circle and collect those those green
turbo things and what is figured out is
you don't need to complete the game to
earn their reward
now the more sort of there and despite
being on fire and hitting the wall and
going through this whole process it's
actually achieved at least a local
Optima given the reward function of
maximizing the the number of points and
so the it's it's figured out a way to
earn a higher reward while ignoring the
implied bigger picture goal of finishing
the race which us as humans understand
much better this raises for self-driving
cars ethical questions besides other
questions you can watch this for hours
and it will do that for hours and that's
the point is it it's it's hard to teach
it's hard to encode the formally define
a utility function under which an
intelligent system needs to operate and
that's made obvious even in a simple
game and so what is yep question so the
question was what's an example of a
local optimum that an autonomous car so
similar to the coast racer what would be
the example in the real world for an
autonomous vehicle and it's a touchy
subject but it would certainly have to
be involved the the choices we make
under near crashes and crashes the
choices a car makes when to avoid for
example if the if there's a crash
imminent and there's no way you can stop
just prevent the crash do you do you
keep the driver safe or do you keep the
other people safe and there has to be
some
even if you even if you don't choose to
acknowledge it even if it's only in the
data and the learning that you do
there's an implied reward function there
and we need to be aware of that reward
function is because they may may find
something until you actually see it
we won't know it once we see it we'll
realize that oh that was a bad design
and that's the scary thing it's hard to
know ahead of time what that is so the
recent breakthroughs from deep learning
came several factors first is the
compute Moore's law CPUs are getting
faster a hundred times faster every
decade then there's GPUs also the
ability to Train neural networks and
GPUs and now Asics has has created a lot
of capabilities in terms of energy
efficiency and being able to Train
larger networks more efficiently there
is larger well first of all in the in a
21st century this digitized data there's
larger data sets of digital data and now
there is that data is becoming more
organized not just vaguely available
data out there on the Internet it's
actual organized data sets like imagenet
certainly for natural language there's
large data sets
there is the algorithm innovations back
prop back propagation commercial neural
network cell STM's all these different
architectures for dealing with specific
specific types of domains and tasks
there's the huge one is the
infrastructure is on the software in the
hardware side there's get ability to
share in an open source way software
there is pieces of software that but
that make robotics and make machine
learning easier ross 10
floo there's a Amazon Mechanical Turk
which allows for efficient cheap
annotation of large scale data sets as
AWS and the cloud hosting machine
learning hosting the data and the
compute and then there's a financial
backing of large companies Google
Facebook Amazon but really nothing has
changed there really has not been any
significant breakthroughs we're using
the exact emotional networks have been
around since the 90s
neural networks have been around since
the 60s there's been a few improvements
but the hope is that's in terms of
methodology the compute has really been
the workhorse the ability to do the
hundredfold improvement every decade
holds promise and the question is
whether that reasoning thing I talked
about is all you need is a larger
network that is the open question so
some terms for deep learning
first of all deep learning is a PR term
for neural networks it is a term for
utilizing it's a port for deep neural
networks when you're all networks to
have many layers it is symbolic term for
the newly gained capabilities that
compute has brought us that that
training on GPUs have brought us so deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
there's many other methods that are
still effective the terms that we
they'll come up in this class is first
of all multi-layer perceptron deep
neural networks recurrent neural
networks LST M long short term memory
networks cnn/orc on Nets convolutional
neural networks deep belief networks and
the operation they'll come up is
convolution pooling activation functions
and back propagation
no question
so the question was what is the purpose
of the different layers in your neural
network what does it mean to have one
configuration versus another so a neural
network is having several layers it's
the only thing you have an understanding
of is the inputs and the outputs you
don't have a good understanding about
what each layer does there are
mysterious things your networks so I'll
talk about how with every layer it forms
a higher level a higher order
representation of the input so it's not
like the first layer does localization
the second layer does path planning the
third layer does navigation how you get
from here to Florida or maybe it does
but we don't know so we know we're
beginning to visualize neural networks
for simple tasks like for imagenet
classifying cats versus dogs we can tell
what is the thing that the first layer
does the second layer of the third layer
and we'll look at that
but for driving when you as the input
provide just the images and the output
the steering it's still unclear what you
learned partially because we don't have
neural networks that dry successfully
yet
so this this is the question was D D F
does a neural net will generate layers
over time like does it grow it that's
one of the challenges is that a neural
network is predefined the architecture
is the number of nodes the number of
layers
that's all fixed unlike the human brain
where neurons die and are born all the
time and you know network is
pre-specified that's it that's all you
get and if you want to change that you
have to change that and then retrain
everything so it's fixed so what I
encourage you is to proceed with caution
because there's this feeling when you
first teach a network with very little
effort how to do some amazing task like
classify a face versus non face or your
face versus other faces or cats versus
dogs it's an incredible feeling and then
you there's there's definitely this
feeling that I'm an expert but what you
realize is it's we you don't actually
understand how it works and getting it
to perform well for more generalized
tasks for larger scale data sets for
more useful applications requires a lot
of hyper parameter tuning figuring out
how to tweak little things here and
there and it's still in the end you
don't understand why it works so damn
well so deep learning these deep neural
network architectures is
representational learning this is the
difference between traditional machine
learning methods where for example for
the task of having an image here as the
input the input to the network's here is
on the bottom the output is that up atop
so and the input is a single image of a
person in this case and so the input
specifically is
all of the pixels in that image RGB the
different colors of the pixels in the
image and over time what what a network
does is build multi-resolution already
de the first layer builds learns the
concept of edges for example the second
layer starts to learn composition of
those edges corners contours then it
starts to learn about object parts and
finally actually provide a label for the
entities that are in the input and this
is the difference between traditional
machine learning methods where the
concepts like edges and corners and
contours are manually pre specified by
human by human beings human experts for
the particular domain and representation
matters because figuring out a line for
the Cartesian coordinates of this
particular data set where you want to
design a machine learning system that
tells the difference between green
triangles and blue circles is difficult
there's no line that separates them
cleanly and if you were to ask a human
being a human expert in the field to try
to draw that line they would probably do
a PhD on it and still not succeed but a
neural network can automatically figure
out to remap that input and to polar
coordinates where the representation is
such that it's an easily linearly
separable data set and so deep learning
is a subset of representation learning
is a subset of machine learning and a
key subset of artificial intelligence
now because of this because of its
ability to compute an arbitrary number
of features that at the core of the
representation so you're not if you are
trying to detect a cat in an image
you're not specifying 215 specific
features of cat ears and whiskers and so
on that a human expert will specify you
allow and you'll now we discover tens of
thousands of such features which may be
for cats you are an expert but for a lot
of objects you may never be able to
sufficiently provide the the features
which successfully will be used for
identifying the object and so this kind
of representation learning one is easy
in the sense that all you have to
provide is inputs and outputs all you
need to provide is a data set that you
care about without hand engineering
features and to because of the its
ability to construct arbitrarily sized
representations deep neural networks are
hungry for data the more data we give
them the more they're able to learn
about this particular data set so let's
look at some applications first some
cool things that deep neural networks
have been able to accomplish up to this
point let me go through them first the
basic one
ALX net is for image net is a famous
data set and it's a competition of
classification and localization where
the task is given an image identify what
are the five most likely things in that
image and what is the most likely and
you have to do so correctly so on the
right there's an image of a leopard and
you have to correctly classify that
in fact they leopard so they're able to
do this pretty well given a specific
image determine that it's a leopard and
we started what's shown here on the
x-axis is years on the y-axis is error
in classification so starting from 2012
on the left with Alex net and today the
errors decreased from 16 percent and 40
percent before then with traditional
methods have decreased to below 4
percent so human level performance if I
were to give you this picture of a
leopard there's a 4/4 percent for 4
percent of those pictures of leopards
you would not say it's a leopard that's
human level performance so for the first
time in 2015
convolutional neural networks outperform
human beings that in itself is
incredible that's something that seemed
impossible and now is because it's done
it's not as impressive but I just want
to get to why that's so impressive
because the computer vision is hard now
we as human beings have evolved visual
perception over millions of years
hundreds of millions of years so we take
it for granted but computer vision is
really hard visual perception is really
hard
there's illumination variability so it's
the same object the only way we tell
anything is from the shade the little
reflection of light from that surface
it's it could be the same object we
drastically in terms of pixels
drastically different looking shapes and
we still know it's the same object there
is pose variability and occlusions
probably my favorite caption for an
image for a figure in a academic paper
is deformable and truncated cat these
are pictures you know cats are famously
are deformable they could take a lot of
different shapes
it's arbitrary poses are are possible so
you have to have computer vision needs
to know still the same object still the
same class of objects given all the
variability in the posts and occlusions
is a huge problem we still know it's an
object we still know it's a cat even
when parts of it are not visible and
sometimes large parts having enough
visible and then there's all the inter
class variability in inter class all of
these on the top two rows are cats
many of them look drastically different
and the top bottom two rows are dogs
also look drastically different and yet
some of the dogs look like cats so the
cats look like dogs and as human beings
are pretty good at telling a difference
and we want computer vision to do better
than that it's hard so how's this done
is this is done with convolutional
networks the input to which is a raw
image here's an input on the left of a
number 3 and I'll talk about through
convolutional layers that image is
processed pass through convolutional
layers maintain spatial information on
the output they in this case predicts
which of the images what number is shown
in the image 0 1 2 through 9 and so this
these networks that is this is exactly
everybody is using the same kind of
network to determine exactly that input
is an image output is a number and in
the case of you know probability that
it's a leopard what is that number
then there's segmentation built on top
of these convolutional neural networks
where you chop off the end and
convolution eyes the network you chop
off the end where the output is a heat
map so you can have instead of a
detector for a cat you can do a cat heat
where it's the part of the image the
output heatmap gets excited the neurons
on that output get excited and the
spatially spatially excited in the parts
of the image that contain a tabby cat
and this kind of process can be used to
segment the image into different objects
a horse so the original input on the
left is a woman on a horse and the
output is a is a fully segmented image
of knowing where's the woman where's the
horse and this kind of process can be
used for object detection which is the
task of detecting an object in an image
now the traditional method will
accomplish in your networks and in
general in computer vision is the
sliding window approach we have a
detector like the leopard detector that
you slide through the image to find
where in that image is a leopard this
the segmenting approach the our CNN
approach is efficiently segment the
image in such a way that it can propose
different parts of the image that are
likely to have a leopard or in this case
the cowboy and that drastically reduces
the computational requirements of the of
the object detection task and so they're
these networks this is the currently one
of the best networks for the image net
task of localization is the dippers deep
residual networks they're deep
so VG g19 is one of the famous ones ve
Jeana you started to get above 20 layers
in many cases 34 layers is the resin
that one so the lesson there is the
deeper you go the more representational
power you have the higher accuracy but
you need more data
it's other applications colorization of
images so this again input is a single
image and output is a single image so
you can take black and white video from
a film from an old film and recolor it
and all you need to do to train that
network in the supervisor way is provide
modern films and convert them to
grayscale so now you have arbitrarily
sized datasets that are able to datasets
of greyscale to color and you're able to
with very with very little effort on top
of it to successfully well somewhat
successfully recolor images again Google
Translate does image translation in this
way image to image it first perceives
here in German I believe famous German
correct me if I'm wrong
dark chocolate written in German on a
box so this can take this image detect
the different letters convert them to
text translate the text and then using
the image to image mapping map the
letters the translated letters back onto
the box and you can do this in real time
on video so what we've talked about up
to this point on the left our vanilla
neural networks convolutional neural
networks that map a single input single
output a single image to a number single
image to another image then there is
recurrent neural networks the map this
is the more general formulation that map
a sequence of images or a sequence of
words or sequence of any kind to another
sequence and these networks able to do
incredible things with natural language
with food video and any time series data
for example you can convert text to
handwritten digits
with ham a handwritten text here we type
in and you could do this online type in
deep learning for self-driving cars and
it will use an arbitrary handwriting
style to generate the words deep
learning for self-driving cars this is
done using recurrent neural networks we
can also take car RN ends there called
its character level recurrent neural
networks that train on a data set at an
arbitrary text data set and learn to
generate text one character at a time so
there is no preconceived syntactical
semantic structure that's provided to
the network it learns that structure so
for example you can train it on
Wikipedia articles like in this case and
it's able to generate successfully not
only text that makes some kind of
grammatical sense at least but also keep
perfect syntactic structure for
Wikipedia for markdown editing for late
acting and so on this text says
naturalism and decision for the majority
of Arab countries capital I'd whatever
that means was grounded by the Irish
language by John Clare and so on these
are sentences if you didn't know better
that might sound correct and it does so
any pause one character at a time so
there is these aren't words being
generated this is one character you
start with the beginning three letters
that you generate you completely without
knowing of the word naturalism this is
incredible
you can do this to start a sentence and
let then you know that will complete
that sentence so for example if you
start the sentence with life is or life
is about action
it will complete it with a lot of fun
things the weather life is about kids
life is about the true love of mr. mom
is about the truth now and this is from
Jeffrey hidden the last two if you start
with the meaning of life it can complete
that with the meaning of life is
literary recognition may be true for
some of us here publisher perish and the
meaning of life is the tradition of
ancient human reproduction also true for
some of us here I'm sure
ok so what else can you do you can this
has been very exciting recently is image
caption recognition now a generation I'm
sorry image caption right generation is
important for for large data sets of
images where we want to be able to
determine what's going on inside those
images especially for search if you want
to find a man sitting on a couch with a
dog you type it into Google it's able to
find that so here shown in in black text
a man sitting on a couch of the dog is
generated by the system a man sitting on
a chair with a dog in his lap is
generated by a human observer and again
these annotations are done by detecting
the different obstacles the different
objects in the scene so segmenting the
scene detecting on the right there's a
woman a crowd a cat a camera or holding
you know purple all of these words are
being detected
then a syntactically correct sentence is
generated a lot of them and then you
order which sentence is the most likely
and in this way you can generate very
accurate labeling of the images captions
for the images you could do the same
kind of process for image question
answering you can ask how many is a
quantity how many chairs are there
you can ask about location where where
the right bananas you can ask the bought
the type of object what is the object on
the chair it's a pillow and these are
again using the recurrent neural
networks you could do the same thing
with uh with video caption generation
video captioned the description
generation so looking at a sequence of
images as opposed to just a single image
what is the action going on in this in
this situation this is the difficult
task there's a lot of work in it in this
area now for on the left is correct
description so a man is doing stunts on
his bike or herd of zebras are walking
in the field and on the right there's a
small bus running into a building you
know it's talking about relevant
entities but just doing an incorrect
description a man is cutting a piece of
a piece of a pair of a paper it's
cutting a piece of a pair of a paper so
the words are correct
perhaps but so you're close but no cigar
so one of the interesting things you can
do with the recurrent neural networks is
if you think about the way we look at
images human beings look at images is we
only have a small fovea with which we
focus on in the scene so right now your
periphery is very distorted the only
thing if you're looking at the slides
are you looking at me that's the only
thing that's the focus majority of
everything else is out of focus so we
can use the same kind of concept to try
to teach a neural network to steer
around the image both for perception and
generation of those images this is
important first on the general
artificial intelligence point of it
being just fascinating that we can
select selectively steer our attention
but also it's important for things like
drones that have to fly at high speeds
and advise
we're 300 plus frames a second you have
to make decisions so you can't possibly
localize yourself or perceive the world
around yourself successfully if you have
to interpret the entire scene so what
you can do is you can steer for example
here shown is reading reading house
numbers by steering around an image you
could do the same task for reading and
for writing so reading numbers here on
the MLS data set on the left is reading
numbers but you can also selectively
steer a steering network around an image
to generate that image starting with a
blurred image first and then getting
more and more higher resolution as the
steering goes on work here at MIT is
able to map video to audio so hit stuff
with a drumstick silent video and able
to generate the sound that wood
drumstick hitting that particular object
makes so you can get texture information
from that impact so here's the video of
a human soccer player playing soccer in
a state-of-the-art
machine playing soccer and well let me
give him some time to build up
[Laughter]
okay so soccer this is we take this for
granted
but walking is hard object manipulation
is hard
soccer is harder than chess for us to do
much harder on your phone now you have
you can have a chess engine that beats
the best players in the world and you
have to internalize that because the
question is this is a painful video but
the question is where does driving fall
is it closer to chess or is it closer to
soccer for those incredible brilliant
engineers that worked on the most recent
DARPA challenge this would be as very
painful video to watch I apologize this
is a video from the DARPA challenge of
rope of robots struggling with the bait
basic object manipulation and walking
tasks so it's it's mostly a fully
autonomous navigation task
maybe I'll just let this play for a few
minutes for a few moments to to let it
internalize how difficult this task is
of balancing of planning in an under
actuated way where you don't have full
control of everything when when there is
a delta between your perception of what
you think the world is and what the
reality is so their robot was trying to
turn an object that wasn't there and
this is an MIT entry that actually
successfully I believe gotten points for
this because it got into that area
but as as a lot of the teams talked
about the hardest part so with one of
the things the robot had to do is get
into a car and drive it and get out of
the car and there's a few other
manipulation tasks where to walking on
unsteady ground it had to drill a hole
through a wall all these tasks and what
a lot of teams said is the hardest part
the hardest task of all of them is
getting out of the car so it's not
getting into the car it's this very task
that you saw now is is the robot getting
out of the car these are things we take
for granted
so in our evaluation of what is
difficult about driving we have to
remember that some of those things we
may take for granted in the same kind of
way that we take walking for granted
this is this is this is marvex paradox
with Hans Moravec from CMU let me just
quickly read that quote and quote in the
large highly evolved sensory and motor
portions of the human brain is billions
of years of experience about the nature
of the world and how to survive in it so
this is data this is big data billions
of years an abstract thought which is
reasoning the stuff we think is
intelligence is perhaps less than a
hundred thousand years of data old we
haven't yet mastered it and so sorry I'm
inserting my own statements in the
middle of a quote but we it hasn't it's
been it's been very recently that we've
learned how to think and so we respect
it perhaps more than the things we take
for granted like walking the visual
perception and so on but those may be
strictly a matter of data data and
training time and network size
so walking is hard the question is how
hard is driving and the that's an
important question because the margin of
error is small one there's one fatality
per hundred million miles that's the
number of people that died in car
crashes every year one fatality per 100
million miles that's a point zero zero
zero zero zero one percent margin of
error that's through all the time you
spent on the road that is the error you
get we're impressed with imagenet being
able to classify a leopard a cat or a
dog and close to a tab of human level
performance but this is the margin of
error would get with driving and we have
to be able to deal with snow with heavy
rain with big open parking lots with
parking garages any pedestrians that
behaves irresponsibly as rarely as that
happens or just unpredictably again
especially in Boston reflections the
ones especially this is one of some of
the things you don't think about the
lighting variations that blind the
cameras
and the question was if that number
changes if you look at just crashes so
fatalities per crash crashes per oh yeah
so one of the big things as cars have
gotten really good at crashing and not
hurting the anybody so the number of
crashes is much much larger than number
of fatalities which is a great thing
we've built safer cars but still you
know even one fatality is is too many so
this is one one that Google self-driving
car team is quite open about their
performance since hitting public roads
this is from a report that shows the
number of times the driver disengaged
the the car gives up control that it
asks the driver to take control back or
the driver takes control back by force
meaning that they're unhappy with the
decision that the car was making or it
was putting the car or are there
pedestrians or other cars and unsafe
situations and so if you see over time
that there's there's there's been a
total from 2014 to 2015 there's been a
total of 341 times on beautiful San
Francisco roads and I say that seriously
because the weather conditions are great
they're 341 times that the driver had to
elect it to take control back so it's a
work in progress and let me give you
something to think about here this would
neural networks is a big open question
the question of robustness so this is an
amazing paper I encourage people to read
it there's a couple papers around this
topic deep neural networks are easily
fooled so here are eight images where if
given to a neural network is input
accommodation
as input the network with higher than
ninety nine point six percent confidence
says that the image for example in the
top left is a Robin next to it is a
cheetah than an armadillo a panda an
electric guitar a baseball starfish a
king penguin all of these things are
obviously not in the images so the
network can be fooled with noise more
importantly more practically for the
real world adding just a little bit of
distortion a little bit of noise
distortion to the image can force the
network to produce a totally wrong
prediction so here's an example the
there's three columns correct image
classification this slight addition of
distortion and the resulting prediction
of an ostrich for all three images on
the left and a prediction of an ostrich
for all three images on the right this
ability to fool networks easily it
brings up an important point and that
point is that that there has been a lot
of excitement about neural networks
throughout their history there's been a
lot of excitement about artificial
intelligence throughout its history and
not coupling that excitement not
grounding that excitement in the reality
the real challenges around that has
resulted in in crashes in AI winters
when funding dried out and people became
hopeless in terms of the possibilities
of artificial intelligence
so here's in 1958 New York Times article
that said the Navy revealed the embryo
of an electronic computer today this is
when the first perceptron that I talked
about was implemented in hardware by
Frank Rosenblatt it took 400 pixel image
input and it provided a single output
weights were in
and hardware potentiometers and weights
were updated with electric motors now
New York Times wrote the Navy revealed
the embryo vanilla electronic computer
today that expects we'll be able to walk
talk see write reproduce itself and be
conscious of its existence dr. Frank
Rosenblatt a research psychologist at
the Cornell aeronautical laboratory
buffalo said perceptrons might be fired
to the planets as mechanical space
explorers this might seem ridiculous but
this was the general opinion of the time
and as we know now perceptrons cannot
even separate a nonlinear function
they're just linear classifiers and so
this led to two major AI winters in the
70s and in the late 80s and early 90s
the light Hill report in 1973 by the UK
government said that no part of the
field of discoveries made so far
produced a major impact I was promised
so if the hype builds beyond the
capabilities of our research reports
like this will come and they have the
possibility of creating another AI
winter so I want to pair the optimism
some of the cool things we'll talk about
in this class with the reality of the
challenges ahead of us the focus of the
research community this is some of the
key players in deep learning what are
the things that are next for deep
learning the five-year vision we want to
run on smaller cheaper mobile devices we
want to explore more in the space of
unsupervised learning as I mentioned and
reinforcement learning we want to do
things
that explore the space of videos more
the recurrent neural networks like being
able to summarize videos or generate
short videos one of the big efforts
especially in the companies will deal in
large data is multimodal learning
learning from multiple data sets with
multiple sources of data and lastly
making money from these technologies
there's a lot of this despite the
excitement there has been an inability
for the most part to make serious money
from some of the more interesting parts
of deep learning and while I got made
made fun of by the TAS for including
this slide because it's shown in so many
sort of business type lectures but it is
true that we're at the peak of a hype
cycle and we have to make sure be given
the large amount of hype and excitement
there is we proceed with caution one
example of that let me mention is we
already talked about spoofing the
cameras spoofing the cameras with a
little bit of noise so if you think
about it
self-driving vehicles operate with a set
of sensors and they rely on those
sensors to convey to accurately capture
that information now what happens
not only when the world itself produces
noisy visual information but what if
somebody actively tries to spoof that
data one of the fascinating things have
been recently done is spoofing of lidar
so these rain lidar is a sensor range
sensor that gives a 3d point cloud of
the objects in the external environment
and you're able to successfully do a
replay attack where you have the car see
people and other cars around it when
there's actually nothing around it in
the same way that you can spoof a camera
to see things that are not there a
neural network so let me run through
some of the libraries that will work
with and that are out there that you
might work with if you proceed with deep
learning tensorflow that is the most
popular one these days it's heavily
backed and developed by Google it has a
primarily a Python interface and is very
good at operating on multiple GPUs
there's Kerris and also TF learn and TF
slim which are libraries that operate on
top of tensorflow that make it slightly
easier slightly more user friendly
interfaces to get get up and running
if you're interested to get in at the
low-level tweaking of the different
parameters of neural networks creating
your own architectures torch is
excellent for that with its own Lua
interface law as a programming language
and heavily backed by Facebook
there's the old-school TN oh just what I
started on a lot of people early on in
deep learning started on it's one of the
first libraries that supported the head
came with GPU support it definitely
encourages with lower-level tinkering
and as a Python interface and many of
these if not all rely on invidious and
videos library for for doing some of the
low-level computations involved with
training these neural networks on NVIDIA
GPUs MX net heavily supported by Amazon
and they've officially recently
announced that they're going to be with
their AWS going to be all in on MX net
neon recently bought by Intel started
out as a manufacturing a manufacturer of
a neural network chips which is really
exciting and it performs exceptionally
well I hear good things cafe started in
Berkeley also was very popular in Google
before tensorflow came out he's
primarily designed for computer vision
with cons nets but it's now expanded to
all they're all of the domains there is
CNT K as he used to be known and now
called the Microsoft cognitive toolkit
nobody calls it that still I'm aware of
it says multi-gpu support has its own
brain script custom language as well as
other interfaces and will get to play
around in this class is amazingly deep
learning in the browser right our
favorite is ComNet je s what you use
built by Andre karpati from Stanford now
open AI it's good for explaining the
basic concept of neural networks it's
fun to play around with all you need is
a browser some very few requirements it
can it can't leverage GPUs unfortunately
but for a lot of things that we're doing
you don't need GPUs you'll be able to
train at work with very little and
relatively efficiently without the need
of GPUs it has full support for CNN's
rnns
and even deep reinforcement learning
Chara's j/s which seems incredible we
tried to use for this class didn't
didn't happen - it has GPU support so it
runs in the browser with GPU support
with opengl or however it works
magically but we're able to accomplish a
lot of things we need without the use of
GPUs so I should it's incredible to live
in a day and age when it literally as
I'll showing the tutorials it takes just
a few minutes to get started with
building your own neural network that
classifies images and a lot of these
libraries are friendly in that way so
all the references mentioned in this
presentation are available at this link
and the slides are available there as
well so I think in the interest of time
let me wrap up thank you so much for
coming in today and tomorrow I'll
explain the deep reinforcement learning
game and the actual competition and how
you can win it thanks very much guys